a newly released text between FBI agents
is raising questions about what former
President Obama said about his lack of
involvement in federal investigations on
September 2nd 2016
Lisa Paige texted her friend Peter
struck about the need to create talking
points for then FBI director Jim Comey
that was because she texted quote POTUS
the president wants to know everything
we are doing now that would appear to
contradict what then President Obama
told Fox's Chris Wallace five months
earlier I talked to the Attorney General
about pending investigations I do not
talk to FBI directors about pending
investigations they we have a strict
line and always have maintained it
joining us now with more is James
Freeman of the Wall Street Journal who
joins us from New York Republican
Congressman Jim Jordan is here in the
studio as his Democratic strategist
Scott Bolden congressman yep your sense
on this now the Democrats are saying
this is not a big deal this is the
president being engaged on the subject
of Russian collusion and interference in
the election which a president of the
United States should be informed in you
got to take it in context this is
September 2nd remember July 5th is the
day they say we're not going to charge
Clinton Comey does is now famous press
conference and saying no charges will be
brought waiter that's a month Peter
struck the same guy who ran the Clinton
investigation opens the Russia Trump
investigation two weeks later August
14th we have the text message from
struck and page where Peter struck says
we need an insurance policy in case the
American people actually make balance
from president and then two weeks after
that September 2nd they say POTUS needs
to know everything we are doing so take
it in context I think it raises lots of
concerns lots of suspicion that's why we
need to look into it and find out
exactly what's going on Scott well
listen Barack Obama's not walking
through that White House door he's a
private citizen and the mere fact that
you have dates you have these details at
all amounts to conjecture doesn't amount
to anything definite you could look into
it if you want but we got a Russian
investigation as to whether Russia
meddled in our elections and whether
Donald Trump connected to that had any
collusion or had anything to do with
that investigation we got to be focused
on that whether you're democrat or
republican that ought to be the focus
these dates and these possibilities and
conjecture are waste of time more here's
the broader context the broader context
is they have all these text message we
say Trump is awful Trump [ __ ] and Winnie
should lose 100 million - doesn't mean
the investigations bias it animal view
but that mean is tainted and even the
fives are worn in the memo doesn't mean
anything's dated I just biased I took
action
let's get James Freeman and here James
you hear the discussion the spin today
from the Democrats was this is easily
explained because the president should
be aware of any efforts to investigate
as the chief executive officer of the
government investigate a Russian effort
to meddle in the election regardless of
what political parties involved your
response well it does sound like
progress if Democrats are acknowledging
that the FBI the Justice Department do
report to the president that they're not
an authority unto themselves but I think
it really does get to this question of
who did authorize going to a judge and
getting a warrant to spy on the
political opposition with an amount of
evidence that really would not pass
muster at our newspaper and really in
any professional newsroom and so now the
question is you know it's you mentioned
the Obama statement on your program a
few years ago it's quite a distance from
I never talked to the FBI director about
pending investigations - not only did he
talk but he wanted to know everything
they were doing and I think now the
question for mr. Obama is did you
realize this evidence was so thin did he
know what they were doing going to the
judge in the FISA Court with this
politically generally yeah well the
couple things here Asian yeah well I
think it is it is wild to think that in
the middle of a heated presidential
election cycle with the Justice
Department they're FBI ready to spy on
an American not to go to the presidency
I think that would be weird not to say
look yes we're about to do this
we thought we should give you a heads up
and go to the President and say this is
what we're putting together we think you
should be apprised of this do you think
this is okay I you know maybe I just
what's the proper today telling the full
story your previous segments that the D
the DAP seen the Clinton campaign hire
steel to produce the dossier and they
also told him what to put in the dossier
did they tell him the whole story what
was in the dossier I don't know where
who paid for the dossier probably not
Scott one place one time I'd love to
come on this show or any show and debate
the GOP about facts not conjecture about
facts not guessing we don't even know
whether Barack Obama even asked for that
information you're relying on the text
of Lisa bass there you know Scott your
lawyers I am contemporaneous record you
know recordings whether it's in text
messages or text messages are quite
reliable in court because they're
brainian there's no reason for him to
lie about no Laos about it's no reason
for him him or her to say he even to say
he wants to know everything why would
they say that if the president didn't
want to know everything there's an odd
thing to us how they're processing it he
may about the briefing Obama's proxy I'm
going to call him a proxy Eric Holder
was on another network tonight with
Rachel Maddow and I want the congressman
to respond let's watch the real problem
here is the president the president
going after named career people the
president saying things about the
integrity of the those two institutions
the Justice Department the the FBI no
other president has ever said those
kinds of things conducted himself in
that way and he's doing long-term harm I
think any one of my kids would make a
better president than then than Donald
Trump
hilarious Eric no other no other FBI has
taken a campaign opposition research
document taking it to a secret court to
get a secret warrant to spy on a fellow
American citizen I mean that is
unbelievable news going mchavez leaving
Jim Baker the general counsel has been
demoted Andrea Sonic
Lisa page has been demoted and
reassigned Peter struck has been demoted
Andrea side Jim rebecky chief of staff
for James Comey is leaving the FBI
that's who we're talking about reporter
being driven when have you ever seen the
top people the seventh floor
the FBA that many leave this organ
that's the problem and that's what we're
trying to get to the bottom of and and
look at and the text messages give
context to the whole mindset of these
people who ran the Clinton investigation
and then launched and ran the Trump
Russian you do that backwards really
fast going he's got him down the the
Flyers are warned was not the dossier
was not the basis of that we're back at
that we gotta get the last word to free
money stuck out there up your leg with
on the application the judge I think
we'd like to hear from the judge whether
that judge would have wanted the full
story on and as you said these do not
look like middle management decisions
these look like pretty high-level
decisions to spy on your political
adversary let's find out who made them
alright you know what I want to know I
want to know who the FISA judge is I'm
sick of these secret judges able to hide
away what I want to know who the judges
are and I want to know why there's no
sanctions being levied against lawyers
who are omitting material facts from
these secret applications I think it
needs a sanction if I were the judge
where's my gavel here's my gas sanctions
all right guys